a Florida woman has botched an election
and corrupted democracy we will examine
the shenanigans in Florida and why
Democrats are simply incapable of ever
conceding an election then the left gets
honest about abortion and immigration
Michelle Obama calls Donald Trump a
racist and a misogynist and Trump deals
deftly with foreign leaders in France
finally a Veterans Day glimmer of hope
that the left and the right might just
may be toned down as some of the
antipathy I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael nolza
[Music]
so much to get to today so much going on
all around the world and most especially
in that epicenter of botched elections
and pure political corruption Florida
this woman Brenda Snipes the Broward
County elections supervisor is now
performing cartoonishly corrupt acts
that are threatening the integrity of
our democracy as the Democrats just keep
digging and digging those graves to find
a few more dead people and fictional
people to go vote for them and hopefully
push them over the edge in that
governor's race in that Senate race
we'll get to that in a second but first
let's make a little bit of money with
Lending Club this is a good way to do it
this is literally a way to get access to
more money for decades credit cards have
been telling us buy it now pay for it
later with interest and you know that
isn't just a little bit of interest
those become very high interest rates
and despite your best intentions that
interest can get out of control with
Lending Club you can consolidate your
debt or pay off your credit cards with
one fixed monthly payment since 2007
Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans no trips to the bank no high
interest credit cards this is very
important to me as a millennial in
particular because I don't want to go
anywhere when I don't have to I just
want to sit on my couch go to Lending
Club Calm tell them about yours well
specifically go to Lending Club calm /
Knowles Keo wles tell them how much you
want to borrow what terms are right for
you if you're approved the loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days you
don't even need to take a picture of the
check it's just that easy
Lending Club calm / Knowles check your 8
minutes for up to 40 grand Lending Club
time / Knowles Cana wles
Lending Club com / Knowles all loans
made by webb bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender Florida Florida what are
you doing you might have thought you you
fool if you you might have thought that
the elections were over on Tuesday night
maybe they went into Wednesday morning
you know a week ago now six days ago but
you would be wrong
and you would be wrong for two reasons
one because Democrats
not capable ever of conceding any
elections Al Gore is still looking for
votes to become president in 2000
Hillary Clinton I think she's the real
president I'm pretty I think she's
technically the president even though
she didn't win the election she's still
gonna find all those votes
so the one reason Democrats refused to
concede elections second reason Florida
just Florida specifically Broward County
and Palm Beach counties so Broward
County you remember them that's where
there was that awful school shooting
there and a ton of corruption among
those elected officials total negligence
they weren't paying attention to threats
they were just dumping kids back into
the system
the sheriff's were passing the buck I
mean just awful corruption there
this is bled over into the elections
Broward County elections supervisor
Brenda Snipes is discovering every day
more and more votes that were cast for
Democrats that just whoops they forgot
to see them on election night
oopsy-daisy well okay that's fine
overturn the elections Republican Ron de
Santos he didn't really win and scott
rick scott the former governor of
florida republican candidate for senate
he didn't really win it's actually
socialist Andrew Gilliam he's about to
become the governor now he conceded the
race by the way Democrat socialist
Andrew Gilliam he has now unconsidered
because that's Florida for you so right
now according to Politico this woman
Brenda Snipes the Broward County
election supervisor is expected to be
removed from office that's good but it's
about 15 years too late this woman came
in she has been in this job since 2003
she has already been found or accused
and found in violation of counting
unlawful votes destroying ballots
sunshine law violations those are
transparency violations missed deadlines
just within the last couple years after
the 2016 election she was caught
red-handed destroying election ballots
within 12 months you're supposed to keep
those ballots for 22 months to make sure
that you don't do some nefarious elect
meddling and then try to cover your
tracks looks like she was covering her
tracks in also in 2016
she left a ballot proposition off of the
ballot there is a ballot proposition
regarding medical marijuana it was left
off of the ballot probably because
people were using too much of that
Haitian oregano and they managed not
even to include it on some of the bough
not all the ballots some had it some
didn't a total mess
also in 2016 granted she's been in this
job 15 years these three are just within
the last two years in 2016
Broward County posted the election
results to their website before the
polls closed I don't know they must have
been clairvoyant they must have been
telepathic to just know that people were
gonna vote for Democrats in they must
have just known how things were going to
go so they posted that obviously a major
violation to post election results
before the polls closed in 2012 so going
back four years this woman Brenda Snipes
discovered a thousand new ballots
uncounted ballots one week after the
election they just turned up
whoopsie-daisy in 2004 there were 58
thousand mail ballots mail-in ballots
that were not delivered to voters so
voters never had the opportunity to fill
it out or mail it back to the government
that's not even just finding a thousand
votes in a closet somewhere that's fifty
eight thousand people didn't get their
votes so amidst all of this the races
have tightened the races for Senate and
for governor Ron de santis running
against Andrew Gilliam the socialist for
governor and Republican Rick Scott
running against Democrat Bill Nelson for
the Senate and what you're seeing on CNN
NBC MSNBC New York Times forever is that
the polls are tightening right they're
tightening because they're discovering a
bunch of fraudulent ballots that's why
you've got to call it like it is right
now Rick Scott the Republican is only up
0.2 5% on Nelson
so that's 12,500 votes or less this
triggers a hand recount of the election
Ron de Santos
republican is up less than half a
percentage point on Andrew Gilliam
that's less than 33,000 700 votes in
Florida that triggers a machine recount
right away so now they're tightening up
in Broward and Palm Beach County they
found there was a teacher at a polling
place in elementary school who went into
a closet and just magically found a box
of provisional ballots waiting in there
I went this brings us to the definition
of a word by the way provisional ballot
when Democrats discovered provisional
ballots days after the election the
provision that those ballots seek to
rectify is that Republicans won the
election that's the provision so just in
case
Republicans win an election there's a
provision which is called inventing a
bunch of fake ballots to go in there so
Town Hall right now is reporting Laura
Loomer saw that a bunch of other
provisional ballots were found in a
rental car at a Fort Lauderdale Airport
they were found in the trunk of the car
you can actually see some people have
been posting this around Twitter that
these boxes of ballots were being
transported in private cars they were
being loaded onto rental trucks here's
just here's just one example of a guy
who happened to see it happening
my two ladies just walked up there with
the provisional ballots were from
to the precinct and a bag of like you
know the paper ballots and I said them I
go what you just can carry those around
and they said now the truck left them
put the trucks right here so I'm not
real sure what the hell's going on here
I don't think it's right yeah I don't
think it's right either I don't think
that's right people are throwing those
ballots around like as monopoly money
down in Broward County and look we've
had difficult races for years in Florida
constant incompetence but and that's
what Democrats are trying to blame this
on right now they're trying to blame it
on incompetence it's not incompetence
it's corruption they I know I maybe this
woman is also incompetent she clearly is
because she doesn't cover her tracks
very well but this is also rank
corruption because these people will not
concede a race marco rubio has been
tweeting this out he's been tweeting out
updates from the election and the
ongoing election and how days and days
and weeks and weeks go by democrat in
drew Gilliam who had already conceded
the race then unconsidered he said every
vote is gonna count it's gonna count if
it takes a week or a week and a half or
two weeks or whatever and it is true
they're counting a lot of ballots there
are reports of ballots coming out they
only have one candidate filled in just
one Democrat candidate imagining that
scores of people are showing up only
voting for one person and reveal them
and then leaving the polling place
obviously absurd so the I think the fact
that Rubio's tweeting this ad tells us
something Rubio is not a
shoot-from-the-hip kind of guy generally
he's usually pretty thoughtful ease
sometimes a little too cautious and he
is calling this out for what it is rank
corruption also right now one of the
little hidden stories in this is that
the two Democrat campaigns that we're
talking about Gilliam and Nelson are
objecting to a judge rejecting non
citizen ballots this came out we saw a
transcript from the court because
they're fighting us at they're gonna be
fighting this out in court for a while
now and a judge rejected one ballot
because it was a non-us citizen and both
gillum's camp and Nelson's camp
- that they are now openly saying we
want non-citizens votes to be counted
and there's a great irony here which is
that that vote in particular the one
that was ineligible because the person
was not a US citizen yeah I know what
you're thinking you're thinking Latin
American cross the border illegally no
that wasn't the problem it was a name
that seems Eastern European or Russian
Katya and it was described that way as a
phonetic spelling because it was
obviously a foreign name which means I
think conclusively that the Democrats
are colluding with the Russians that's
just a little side part of this story
but it certainly does seem to be the
case consider this we are now six days
out from this election the Republicans
won we know that they won they got more
votes we knew at that night we knew it
the next morning we know it today how
many votes were cast in Broward County
in that election
I'm not saying how many votes were cast
for one person or the other I'm just
saying how many total votes were cast we
don't have an answer for that
Brenda Snipes can't give us an answer
for that the election supervisor nobody
can seem to give us an answer for how
many votes were cast something is
clearly terribly wrong if they can't
even get a number of the people who went
to the polls and the reason that we
can't get that number is because of all
this corruption but you've got to go
after it you've really got to go this is
the same reason why we've got to go
after all of the fake accusers who made
up stories against Brett Kavanaugh who
perjured themselves in some cases the
the reason we have to go after them is
because if we don't punish them
it sets up precedent whereby it will
encourage more people to do this right
now
Christine Ford has made a million
dollars and got a book deal off of her
testimony about which there are many
questions testimony that contradicted
itself many times the very suspect
highly not credible she's gotten a lot
out of that
oh and after afterward more and more
people came up and made up holy full
stories fortunately in that case
accusers like Julie sweat Nick are now
being criminally investigated
Michael avenatti who was pushing and
pimping out women
to make false claims he's being
criminally investigated we need we need
people in Broward County who were
engaging in this kind of corruption to
be wearing orange jumpsuits pre-suit yes
that's serious because especially in a
swing state like Florida that can decide
whole elections the you know certain
counties can decide governor can decide
Senate can decide the president you've
got to make sure that you've got
election integrity and Democrats don't
have a whole lot of that this is also
the moral hazard of turning election day
into election season you hear this all
the time from the left they say we need
more time to vote
it used to be election day there was one
day now we need more time early voting
we need everybody should get a mail-in
ballot people should have to opt out of
mail-in ballots we have all of these
mail-in ballots coming in all of these
provisional ballots being cast we saw
undercover from project very to us that
election workers were encouraging
non-citizens to vote around this country
that's the trouble is when it goes on
for days and days and weeks and weeks to
vote then the counting of those ballots
tends to go on for days and days and
weeks and weeks because there's just so
much more room for shenanigans and this
is the downside of that for years when
the left has tried to make election day
for wider because the left is much
better at stealing elections than the
right you know I'm not saying
Republicans have never tried to pull a
dirty trick or nothing but the Democrats
really seem to have made an industry out
of it they really made it out of the
political machines Tammany Hall and
they've just mastered it there's Chicago
machines that still exist
we elected a Chicago machine politician
to be President and Barack Obama they're
just really good at it giving them more
time gives them more opportunity to
steal elections and this is the flip
side of it is when you you say why
wouldn't you want more voting you say
because I want every vote to count and
when you will allow these sorts of
shenanigans to go on you're cancelling
out people's votes more votes is not
always the best thing in the world
especially when some of those votes are
fraudulent we already know that many of
the votes down there or fraudulent and
every fraudulent vote that's cast
negates deprives a fellow American of
there
own right to vote it takes a vote away
from every single one of them you don't
hear that too much but that's the way it
is and I think Republicans have have
shied away from this issue they should
embrace it because it's really serious
and you're never gonna be Democrats of
this game you're never gonna beat them
at stealing elections and machine
politics not that you would want to in
the first place it's it's wrong it's
it's very unethical but also technically
speaking you're just never gonna beat
them they've got too much practice at it
now if Democrats are being dishonest in
Florida which they are they are at least
now being honest on a couple of issues
like abortion and illegal immigration
you might have seen this ad there is now
an ad for Planned Parenthood wasn't put
out by Planned Parenthood but it was put
out by a left-wing organization
supporting Planned Parenthood supporting
abortion rights it is the most honest
abortion ad that has ever been made take
a look
she does see a cute little baby wearing
one of those pink hats like from the
women's March it says she deserves to be
loved mm-hmm yeah oh she's so cute look
at that little baby uh-huh she deserves
to be wanted yeah yes that would be nice
okay still there's no way that they
could turn this cute ad into the worst
thing ever made could they she deserves
to be a choice oh they did it okay they
did it they turned a very cute ad of a
baby into absolutely a horrifying
monstrosity hashtag stand with PP
Planned Parenthood ap Action Fund this
was produced by something called the
agenda project I kid you know when I saw
that ad I refused to cover it I didn't
want to tweet about it because I was
certain that it was a right-wing hoax I
was certain of it and I didn't want to
be accused of spreading fake news I said
it's so on the nose you know the trouble
with us right-wingers we're just not
creative enough we're just I don't know
we're not subtle enough oh no it was a
real ad it's so horrifying now the thing
I like about this ad is that it's honest
the agenda project it's a legit
organization it's a left-wing
organization it's promoting a
progressive agenda and this is to help
out their friends Planned Parenthood
but it's so honest I bet every point
first of all it shows the baby so often
in the debates about abortion you'll say
well unborn babies shouldn't be killed
in the womb and they'll say don't call
it a baby it's up fetus and then you
point out to them that the word fetus
just means baby it just means offspring
it's a latin word and they say well
that's just semantics and you say right
semantics means meaning never mind we're
digressing here so they show the baby
first of all you say thank you thank you
for being honest there and then they use
the correct pronoun because when the
left talks about fetuses they say it
it's not a life it's not living it's not
a human it's not a baby but this
advertisement says she says she deserves
to be loved she deserves she deserves
so it's admitting this is a person there
is a pronoun here she has a personality
she has characteristics okay and what's
interesting then about the subtext or
they rather the captioning is that it's
almost entirely wrong it actually gets
everything completely backwards and I
think this is how they get their logic
backwards too so even that the first
sentence she deserves to be loved no she
doesn't
nobody deserves to be loved this is
actually sort of the the basis of all of
our all of our thought about ourselves
about humanity about God theology
philosophy is that mankind is imperfect
we are not perfect were broken were
flawed there is original sin we have
fallen out of the garden we're never
going to be perfect we're always going
to sin that is the trouble the trouble
is that we actually don't deserve to be
loved we want to be loved and we can
love other people and it's a beautiful
thing when we are loved we don't deserve
to be loved the second line in there
they say she deserves to be wanted this
isn't true at all it is not the just
dessert of people to be wanted it is not
no human beings do not deserve to be
wanted all of human history shows this
to be right even today even today in the
United States thirty seven percent of us
birth
or unintended for all of human history
virtually everybody alive has been alive
because you know someone had a little
too much fun one night and mom and dad
went out to the barn or whatever but
it's not that it was planned the whole
idea of planned parenthood is a very new
notion people come in and then they
bring great joy to the world and they
bring abundance and they bring their
creative energies and they bring their
contribution and we're all so grateful
for the gift of life that's why you see
pro-life billboards that say smile your
mother chose life but it's not that you
were wanted even today in America with
rampant abortion a ubiquitous
prophylactics ubiquitous birth control
methods 37 percent of US births are
unintended and just look at those
numbers four million babies are born in
the United States every year 1 million
babies are aborted 20% of babies
conceived each year in the United States
are aborted for a little under actually
a little more than that and a little
under 4 million are born imagine that
number before widespread legal abortion
imagine that number before the invention
of the condom imagine imagine what those
numbers were and so the final line they
say here is she deserves to be a choice
and obviously that's horrifying because
you look at this cute little baby who's
smiling at you and you say no no I don't
want don't know only choose one thing
you don't you can't choose anything to
do with that cute little baby but it
tells you so much about the philosophy
and ideology of the left that the
highest good their final line 1 2 3 the
last punch is choice that is the hot
better than love better than being
wanted or appreciated it's choice and
this is an absurd Idol sometimes you get
this a little bit on the right to me
people make a total Idol out of choice
choice for choices sake this was the
argument for slavery the argument for
slavery was states rights now broadly I
like states rights I like our federalist
experiment I enjoy the separation of
powers between the federal government
the state government in the
local governments but states don't have
the right to do anything and when you're
talking about slavery the reason why
states rights is such a ridiculous
euphemism is because of the obvious
question states rights to do what to do
what our system of government allows
certain rights the philosophical
underpinnings of our civilization permit
certain rights but it prevents other
rights and obviously this is the case
for abortion they say on the left that
if you oppose abortion you're anti
choice I'm anti certain choices I'm for
other choices the choice to do what
there there are certain choices that I
think are bad but should be legal there
are certain choices that are bad but
constitutional there are certain choices
that are awful and should not be legal
should not be permitted and the force of
the state should prevent those choices
one of which is abortion because
abortion stops a beating heart because
abortion stops that little baby we she
does not deserve to be a choice and that
actually the only the I think the only
thing we can say about this commercial
definitively is she does not deserve to
be a choice
she's a human she's a an individual
human life she's she should not be
killed without due process before she
has the chance to smile and be in that
commercial truly wicked stuff but at
least you've got to give him credit for
being honest
they're also being honest on immigration
so this is another issue that you know
remember before the midterm elections
there was all of this talk about the
caravan moving up from Honduras to
Guatemala to Mexico was going to come in
to the United States and it showed
Democrats hands because Republicans were
making a big deal at this Donald Trump
made it a major final pitch for the
midterm elections stop illegal
immigration and Democrats couldn't
answer if they were smart they would
have said we don't want lawless caravans
rolling into the United States but
instead they did two things they denied
that the caravan even existed in the
first place and then when you showed
them video of it they said oh it's fine
it's not a big
stop oh come on now look here's CNN's
Chris ELISA
here's his reporting mocking people who
oppose the illegal immigration it's also
far less scary
then Trump is working hard to make it
out to be so why is he doing it that
well for political gain duh
Trump has weaponized fear of rampant
illegal immigration among his supporters
since he became a candidate for
president back in 2015 and now with the
midterm elections just days away
Trump is amping up his rhetoric even
more not only painting a picture of a
ravaging hoard charging toward our
borders but suggesting that there may be
some terrorist elements who are using
the caravan to secure entry into the
u.s. how does a person with that voice
become the chief political guy for CNN
oh my gosh I don't even know how to do
that and for you know my my voice is a
couple octaves lower so I don't even
know if I get even but just that wow wow
oh my gosh that's just CNN CNN in a
larynx but what he's saying is also
awful too it's not just how he's saying
and part of how he's saying it is that
he's mocking people who have these
concerns and and it's that constant
condescension that you get from voxcom
you get it from CNN where they say come
on it's not really a big deal no it is a
big deal it's a big deal when people
break our laws and invade our country
and access the social safety net here
are the facts there was an illegal alien
who just murdered three people in the
United States
he murdered three people after a
sanctuary release he was in jail
ice wanted to pick him up and the jail
that he was being held in Middlesex
County Jail in New Jersey ignored Isis
requests they would not turn this guy
over to ice when he was released from
jail because they supported giving him
sanctuary this is what sanctuary cities
do they end up with people who commit
violent crimes when they should have
been deported it's a 23 year old Mexican
national he killed two men he wounded
two others he killed a woman that
next day and Middlesex County Jail
doesn't care they ignored the detainer
placed by ice they wanted this guy to
roam free immigration illegal
immigration in particular has become an
increasingly difficult problem to deal
with there is a surge going on right now
with the left likes to point out like
Chris ELISA they say oh the caravan it's
not a big deal it's look it was 15,000
people now it's only a thousand or two
thousand that's not a big deal and in a
sense they're right it's not a big deal
because thousands of people cross our
borders every single day right now we
are seeing a surge in illegal
immigration this past month is 40
percent higher than any other month on
record we've seen a 400% spike since
last year why has it spiked it decreased
dramatically when President Trump was
elected because people thought that he
would be very harsh to illegal aliens
who came in what they then learned is
that our system our legal system for
immigration is so broken that not even
Donald Trump could fix it and so you saw
those numbers flow over again you're
also seeing that because of all of the
economic opportunity caused by the
booming economy right now in certain
areas along the border there has been a
4,000 percent increase in arrests in
just the past month border patrol caught
51 thousand people 51 thousand people so
you're thinking it's already one and a
half people or one and a half thousand
people per day but then another 10,000
people showed up they didn't cross the
border and try to run and evade law
enforcement they showed up at the border
and demanded to be allowed in and what
do we do because we have an absurd
immigration policy we let them right in
so now you're up to 2,000 people per day
for the last month what is the cost of
them because chrysalis is there he's
sitting in his lovely cocktail bar in
Manhattan he's swirling his his Negroni
and he says oh it's not a big deal that
they come over here it's very expensive
it's a very expensive it's not only a
violation it's not only so anti-american
that the first act that these people
committed once they're in the country is
to violate our
but it's also expensive in its trains or
social safety programs it costs $10,000
to deport illegal aliens that's just to
deport them do you know how much it
costs to keep them here seventy thousand
dollars it's seven times higher you'll
often hear people say Oh immigration is
a net benefit oh these people are
working hard
oh sure that might be true they might be
great people who work hard and go to
church on Sunday but they cost the
government a lot of money just to deport
somebody $10,000 but to keep them here
if you don't deport them if they're just
accessing social services seventy grand
per person these these levels now are a
new high they've broken the record of
2011 during the feckless Obama foreign
policy and that is why nationalism is so
popular now there's a little tiff
between the the bromance of Donald Trump
and French president Emmanuel Mahone
over the weekend there's a little a
little lover's spat over the question of
nationalism we'll get to that in just a
second we'll also get to Michelle Obama
reminding us all why she's so awful and
a glimmer of hope on Veterans Day a
actual nice moment between the left and
the right a clamor of hope all of that
though only once you go to daily wire
comm and what do you get if you
subscribe to daily wire today you will
get the next chapter of another kingdom
Andrew clave ins narrative podcast
performed by little ole me
today's subscribers get exclusive access
to episode 7 title to the secret of
horror mansion if you're not a
subscriber you can listen to the entire
episode on Friday via YouTube or
SoundCloud but subscribers get to watch
the full show and they get to watch it
with all the cool artwork and it just
looks really really neat so go over to
daily wire calm right now subscribe to
watch the full the full first and second
seasons of another Kingdom also what do
you get you get me at the end of clip
and show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you test questions in the mailbag you
have to ask questions in the
conversation you test questions on
backstage you get all that stuff most
importantly you get the leftist ears
tumblr I feel like you right now if you
haven't subscribed I'm on the road you
know I'm drinking my coffee out of this
little paper cup and it's it's weakening
I can tell it's gonna it's going to get
my clothes damp you don't want that
this is an fda-approved to handle the
the Saline levels Sayle says that how
you pronounce that word say live the
salinity of the leftist tears is so
strong that you cannot use any vessel
other than on the left is tears tumbler
go to daily wire calm we'll be right
back with a lot more
a little lover's spat on the question of
nationalism you remember a few weeks ago
at the height of the midterm elections
President Trump came out he said
thoroughly I am a nationalist here is it
sort of became old-fashioned it's called
a nationalist and I say really we're not
supposed to use that word you know what
I am I'm a nationalist okay
yeah Trump a great point and he explains
in that very speech he says there
globalists in their nationalist their
people who think we should preserve our
freedom in the nation-state there are
people who think we should give away our
national freedom to super natural super
super national and transnational bodies
like the United Nations or the European
Union that have no particularly loyal to
us or our country or people but we're
going to give it away for some
progressive fantasy of some global
Empire or something like that
he describes those differences Emmanuel
macron for Donald Trump's former buddy
and the head of France during an
Armistice Day observance over the
weekend came out swinging in a jab that
was clearly intended for president from
your dismay patriotism is the exact
opposite of nationalism nationalism is a
betrayal of patriotism in saying our
interests first whatever happens to the
others you raise the most precious thing
a nation can have that which makes it
live that which causes it to be great
and that which is most important its
moral values okay sure I guess what he's
trying to do is draw a distinction
between nationalism and patriotism he's
not the first guy to do it it's not only
the left that does this the right does
this sometimes to William F Buckley Jr
was very fond of saying that he was
thoroughly a patriot but he hadn't a
drop of nationalism in him and rich
Lowry the current editor of National
Review has never been able to figure out
quite what he meant by that George
Orwell wrote an essay describing the
difference between patriotism and
nationalism and it's a lot of people
drawing up a lot of false distinctions
there is no difference it's love of
country patriotism is love of country
and I suppose as a if there is any
distinction at all it is that
nationalism is the formalized global
structure of patriotism it's love of
country defined within the borders of
the nation-state
but they're the same thing there
I've looked up many definitions of
patriotism and nationalism I've never
really been able to see the great
difference I think it's a distinction
without a difference and so it's love of
country okay it's love of the
nation-state which has been our system
of global order more or less for 400
years what does that mean why do we
support nations it's because when you
have political bodies and when you have
the world identified and organized into
political bodies that are too small then
things get a little chaotic they get a
little anarchic when you have the world
organized into political bodies that are
too large one Empire or two empires
things become oppressive you have
unaccountable people governing you and
quashing the rights and the liberties of
nations when you have nation-states that
seems to be the sweet spot and that's
what President Trump is talking about in
macron is saying that when you are a
nationalist you turn your back on the
values that make our countries great
what values what values is he talking
about you notice he never mentions the
values what is immoral what is violates
our values about the nation you know
there was a time not so long ago that
nationalism was our values when we said
because of the values that undergird our
civilization we are going to break up
our Western empires and give national
sovereignty to former colonial powers
Indian nationalism was our values
remember when that was they say these
overseas empires that's not our values
we need to give them the Liberty to
govern themselves
now we've flipped it on its head because
Western powers as usual are trying to
colonize different places all over the
world all over not just their continent
but even beyond their continents what
does that mean our values now if that
meant that we agreed that the West was a
Christian a Christian place that we had
various nations here but we all had
Christian values as was the case in the
West for at least a thousand years a
little bit more than a thousand years
then
maybe it would be okay if we had that
cultural and religious unity than
perhaps it would be okay to be a unified
body but were not what he's talking
about our values is he's alluding to
secularism liberal secularism the
project of the Enlightenment that tries
to recreate the philosophical and
ethical systems of the West without the
God that made all of those systems and
it's just weak sauce it's why when he
talks about these things when you hear
someone's try to draw these distinctions
it's never that convincing because
they're just saying words that don't
convey a lot of meaning so how did
President Trump respond you remember
this is a 100th anniversary of Armistice
Day at the end of World War one on the
11th of November at 11:00 in the morning
and 11-11-11 and so president from could
have gotten up there and rebuked him or
disagreed with him or punched back but
he didn't do it and I think this was
very smart this underlines my contention
that Donald Trump is not a reactive guy
he doesn't take things personally he
doesn't get petty he isn't brought out
of by his brought about by his passions
and easily excitable I don't think he's
that at all I think he's quite
meticulous and strategic about what he's
doing and that now it's what he was
doing here he ignored micron they
actually asked him what he thought about
macarons comments he said oh they were
nice yeah they were heartwarming lovely
great okay whatever
moving on because it wouldn't have been
the place to do it and had he refuted
him there they would say that he was
exploiting the remembrance of our fallen
heroes of the First World War and
exploiting veterans day and not living
up to the ideals of the presidency okay
so he's gonna wait and fight that one
another day who cares what Mike Ron
thinks he's the president of France he
would be the he would he would be the
Vichy governor if it wasn't for us I
don't really I don't really care it and
I already do that France a nation that's
regularly tried to conquer much of the
world are given into powers that were
conquering the world is now lecturing us
about how awful independent nations that
protect the liberties of their
constituents how awful that is okay give
me a break
speaking of president Trump ignoring
some hate directed at him Michelle Obama
is back
she is reminding us how awful she is
she's got a new book coming out called
be coming is that not the most
pretentious left-wing deconstruction
just this up becoming oh I'm just I'm
becoming I'm I'm Michelle Obama I
haven't done anything but I am becoming
me I am B I'm just being and that's so
good isn't that so wonderful so she's
out pushing this book becoming and on
the cover Eunice is becoming Michelle
Obama because the Obamas are perhaps the
most narcissistic couple to occupy the
Oval Office in modern history and she's
giving these she's giving these book
tours now doing all of the media tours
and she describes she goes right for
Trump's throat she describes how she was
willing to rebuke him before the entire
world at his inauguration I made my own
opteka justement I stopped even trying
to smile people want to hear more from
you about what's currently going on and
there is a fine line that you and your
husband as previous administrations have
done is that you have to step back and
let the current one do what it's doing
but I think it's safe to say that during
your husband's presidency it was no
drama Obama no drama Obama so what goes
through your mind when you read and hear
all that's going on right now with this
administration I said what I continue to
say being the commander in chief is a
hard job and you need to have discipline
and you need to read and you need to be
knowledgeable you need to know history
you need to be careful with your words
is that right Michelle you need to be
careful with your words like for
instance for instance if Syria threatens
to use chemical weapons against its own
people and then for instance you draw a
red line and you put the credibility of
the United States in the United States
military on that line and say if you do
this again we're gonna go in and stop
you and then Syria goes in and
as its own people again and you do
nothing would that be an instance where
your words matter and you need to choose
your words carefully and you need to
know history and you need to know the
implications of the policies that you're
pursuing is that right is that speaking
of using your words carefully would it
be like for instance if you were a First
Lady of the United States your husband
had just been elected the first black
president and you said that the election
of your husband was the first time that
you were ever proud of your country
would that would that maybe be not the
best choice of words should you maybe
have chosen your words more carefully
here at some sword and of course the
woman interviewing Michelle Obama
I love the the premises she says you
know I think it's safe to say that
you're Obama's your husband's presidency
was no drama Obama isn't that safe to
say would you is that safe no drama like
when you ignore the warning signs and
the pleas for help from our consulate in
Benghazi and then Al qaeda-affiliated
terrorists attack that on the
anniversary of September 11th and then
you lie about it and cover it up and say
it was caused spontaneously by YouTube
video or when you're running guns down
across our southern border and then
those guns are used to kill Americans
would that be maybe or when you a
criminal law or when you politicize
rather your Internal Revenue Service to
go after your political opponents and
shut down right-wing groups or when you
politicize your Justice Department to
also go after your political enemies and
would that be would that be drama is
that any drama would you say I don't
know is that maybe when you try to take
every little event that you can and
exploit it to divide Americans along
racial and sexual lines like for
instance when the Supreme Court makes a
decision to randomly redefine marriage
just cuz because Anthony Kennedy decided
to become a romantic poet one night and
you take this seriously divisive issue
and then you paint the White House in
rainbow colors in white is that would
that be an instance of that or when a
Harvard professor is trying to break
into his own home and there's a conflict
with the local police department and you
turn that into an
national news story and say that the
police department acted stupidly would
that mean you'd make it an entirely
racial question would that be I don't I
could go on all day I could go on all
day Michelle but then of course I would
miss the central point which is that
Michelle Obama has the explanation for
every one of their own airs for the
whole reason that the u.s. ultimately
rejected the Obamas rejected the Obama
legacy and rejected all of the all of
the policies that Barack Obama tried to
institute here's can you guess can you
guess the reason here it is her book she
writes our presence in the White House
had been celebrated by millions of
Americans but it also contributed to a
reactionary sense of fear and resentment
among others the hatred was old and
being and as dangerous as ever okay it's
racism it's all that's it so they just
don't like them because they're black
right that's the only it couldn't be all
of the other all of the other issues
like the terrible economy and the
trotting over all of our liberties and
try undermining the Constitution left
and right and politicizing the federal
good intent so she blames racism for
everything she takes no responsibility
this is classic Democrat handbook and
then she calls Donald Trump a racist in
the book and then she says this quote
what if someone with an unstable minds
loaded a gun and drove to Washington
what if that person went looking for our
girls Donald Trump with his loud and
reckless innuendos was putting my
family's safety at risk and for this I'd
never forgive him you're doing the same
thing you're calling him she calls him
verbatim a misogynist in the book she
constantly implies that he's a racist
and then she criticizes him for
impugning Barack Obama's character and
inciting the crazies you're doing the
same thing Michelle but of course she's
not nearly introspective enough to see
that navel-gazing perhaps but not
introspective enough at all so it's an
empty title it's an empty memoir I think
my book is as far more content than her
her book does and but I want to leave
this on a high note
it's Veterans Day and there actually is
a good sign of the country coming
together and getting along and
shockingly we see this on Saturday Night
Live because that guy Pete Davidson
ariana grande's ex who insulted Dan
Crenshaw the Republican congressman who
lost an eye from an eye Edie while
serving Afghanistan
he has come out and apologized and they
had a great bit about it here's Davidson
but I mean this from the bottom of my
heart it was a poor choice of words the
man is a war hero and he deserves all
the respect in the world and any good
came of this maybe it was that for one
day the left and the right finally came
together to agree on something that I'm
a dick you think so we good we're good
apology accepted
so it plays the ariana grande some even
goes on in roasts David's in a little
bit but what a gentleman all grace all
class goes on accepts the apology and
it's nice to see this you never see
Democrats doing this very rarely do you
see Democrats doing this and forgiving
and being graceful toward Republicans
you do sometimes see it with Republicans
to Democrats and that is nice when we
see it and then Crenshaw makes a serious
point and it's one I hope we can all
listen to but seriously there's a lot of
lessons to learn here not just that the
left and right can still agree on some
things but also this Americans can
forgive one another who wants to live in
a society without grace or in a society
where we view our countrymen as our
enemies rather than just our political
opponents a great line and even over the
weekend year there's awful fires in
California and James Woods very
conservative right-wing actor and now
Twitter celebrity he was helping out
Alyssa Milano a left-wing lunatic who is
helping to run the women's March and she
was there giving side-eye to Brett
Kavanaugh during those hearings crazy
left-wing lunatic and James Woods was
helping her at retweeting please to get
her horses out of town before the fire
killed them and so that was pretty nice
Alyssa Milano and Debra Messing speaking
of the women's March are now going out
there calling out the anti-semitism that
we see in the women's March that is a
pretty good thing I think in part this
is because Democrats have taken the
house and so it's calmed the Democrats
down a little bit they don't think that
they're gonna be out of power forever
they see that elections kind of ebb and
flow you're seeing a lot more grace on
the part of Republicans here then on the
part of Democrats but that's okay that's
I understand Republicans are gonna act
more graceful and more mature in these
situations if the Democrats can come a
little way too that would go a long way
toward helping us because ultimately
we're all Americans were defended by the
same people we have the same enemies who
want to kill us and we've got the same
brave men and women who are out there
defending us so happy Veterans Day to
all the veterans who are watching and
and an unexpectedly nice political note
to end on before inevitably the
Democrats try to steal some more
elections
for to tomorrow but in the meantime we
can have a good day happy Veterans Day
I'm Michael nose this is the Michael an
old show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018